the most interesting thing in the debate
was out the darlings admission that we
couldn't be stopped from using sterling
totally different from the Chancellor I
lead out put the currency options were
for scotland by also argued persuasively
by a sensible agreement common sense for
a common currency said he'd use it
unilaterally first minister so why would
the Bank of England backup Scottish
banks which were a thousand percent I
suggest you go back to DB can't play a
big our stuff darling you know he had
his chance and he muffed it last night
that was part of the debate they've been
the currency bluff has been called the
Scottish people are calling that Bluff
you were alone with you know I'm talking
about lender of last resort you say
you're using the bank of england's using
the pound unilaterally look like I say
that you cannot know impersonate the No
campaign little campaign had the chance
the bluff has been called the people
have I think overwhelmingly in Scotland
oh and Paul laughter Paul Sean we want
to keep the pound that is a decision
that the Scottish people are being asked
to me that is a sovereign will of the
Scottish people I've explained an
enormous detail where it's good sense
for Scotland is good sense for the rest
of UK we've explained what the other
currency options are for Scotland but
we're fighting a campaign to get a
mandate from the Scottish people to have
common sense from a common currency
that's what won the debate last night
and that's the message that's going to
resonate over the next three weeks just
one one last time very specifically you
said Plan B was to use unilaterally
sterling and the Bank of England at that
point we're not be able to support
sottish banks whatever you are watching
last night your minimum you are on
channel a sky instead of the the BBC
what we explain will the currency
options for Scotland as I said free Plan
B's if you like but we explain why the
currency union a sensible plan for a
sensible currency between Scotland and
England is the thing they're asking for
the mandate for that's what won the
debate last night I mean have a look at
what the people thought averted the
audience thought of it everybody apart
from Sky News apparently this debate is
moving on to people realizing to protect
our national health service we have to
have financial control to have
job-creating powers for Scotland that's
what won the debate get worth the debate
line the people are Scotland earlier
maybe Sky News or catch up the
Queensbury rules though you said that
darling supported a number of
conservative policies
doesn't support you could ride me that I
was the darling is a front man for the
Conservative Party in this campaign for
american conservative how is the darling
is an alliance with the conservative
party in this campaign that is what the
new campaign is know what I want to see
now as though that ousted Islands taking
part move mother debates then let's have
the real leader of the No campaign David
Cameron let's have him in Scotland no
let's see if he can do any better than I
was stopped darling dead i don't think
it will because in the key issues of
protection of our public services for
which we need financial control not just
administrative controller from National
Health Service when the key issues are
job-creating post where I was darlings
totally unable to articulate any job
creating powers on off of the Scotland
if there was a no vote on these issues
yes a winning and winning decisively so
let's see if I see if Mr Cameron is
prepared to come to Scotland and have
the debate perhaps on Sky News and let's
see if we'd work we welcome that said he
could do a better job than his frontline